with spider-man no way home the mcu is
officially broken
i am truly sorry for whatever
and everything i have ever done to you
before we go any further just know
there's major spoilers ahead not just
for the end credit scene thanks to peter
parker and dr strange the multiverse
splits wide open in the third tom
holland spider-man movie in a lot of
ways this movie reaches back to the
prior sony spider-man movies bringing in
all kinds of characters and callbacks
that had nothing to do with the mcu
until now but the biggest change for the
marvel cinematic universe happens in the
movie's post-credits scene which
acknowledges for the first time ever on
ongoing superhero series set outside the
mcu bad guy right yep
the first spider-man no way home post
credits scene picks up around the same
time the events in new york come to a
close with doctor strange casting a new
spell to make everyone forget peter
parker again no matter who they are or
what universe they're from the scene
starts with tom hardy's eddie brock
sitting at a tropical bar and talking to
a bartender about the events of the mcu
so far this moment picks up from the
post-credits scene of venom let there be
carnage which sees eddie and the
symbiote wake up in a new universe
apparently the mcu he gets a general
idea that thanos use the infinity stones
to wipe out half of all life in the
universe for five years before the
avengers managed to bring everyone back
an end game but because that he knows a
little about aliens he starts to dispute
the idea until venom tells him he's
drunk and starts to force him to walk
away from the conversation before things
can go any further the lethal protector
is yanked out of the mcu thanks to dr
strange's second spell it's surprising
the film doesn't keep venom in the mcu
it would be a perfect opportunity for
peter to go up against eddie but it does
have one drastic effect on this universe
when eddie is zapped from the bar he
accidentally leaves a part of the
symbiote behind uh-oh
[Music]
[Applause]
the symbiote left behind in the mcu sets
the stage for peter parker to end up
donning the iconic black suit at some
point in a future movie we already know
sony is supposedly planning a brand new
trilogy with tom holland reprising his
role as the young wall crawling hero we
also know holland's peter still lives in
the mcu at the end of spider-man no way
home however his circumstances are
vastly different because everyone has
completely forgotten him thanks to
doctor strange's new spell this allows
spidey to go through almost a total
reset in the mcu
after spider-man first encounters the
symbiote in the marvel comics issue
secret wars number eight he quickly gets
enchanted by the enhanced strength and
speed it gives him now it's not
unreasonable to imagine that the same
might happen to the mcu spider-man since
he'll be operating without most of his
fancy nanotech and will not have access
to other stark industries resources as
such it'll be interesting to see how or
if the symbiote suit affects peter we
know it can do a number on the awareness
personality
[Music]
you want forgiveness
get religion
this event could still set up a future
confrontation between eddie and peter
further down the line too in venom let
there be carnage venom starts to tell
eddie that the symbiote collective mind
knows plenty about other universes so
it's not impossible they'll come looking
for the piece they left behind in the
mcu obviously sony and marvel could
choose to take things in a completely
different direction but as of right now
the future of this universe is wide open
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the marvel cinematic universe are coming
soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]